welcome back well i'm now going to do
some more examples of
i guess a bit of review of some of the
derivatives that we've been seeing and
then i'll introduce you to something
called the chain rule which kind of
expands the universe of the types of
functions we can take the derivatives of
so in the last uh presentation i showed
you if i had a function like let me see
if i had say f of x
is equal to i'm just going to make
something up 10
x to the seventh
plus six
x third
plus
um i don't know 15 x
minus
x to the sixteenth
to take the derivative of this entire
function we take just the derivatives of
each of the pieces right because you can
add them up so f prime of x in this
example
f prime
of x is equal to and i think you get the
hang of at this point it's actually
fairly straightforward we take the 7
multiplied by the 10 so we get 70
x and then
one degree less so 70x to the sixth
plus
x squared
plus 15 right we can kind of view this
as x to the 1 right so it's 1 times 15
times x to the 0 which is 1. so that's
just 15
minus 16
x
to the 15th and i don't want you to lose
sight of what we're actually doing here
what is f prime of x this is the
function that tells us the slope of any
point
of x along the curve f of x so it's a
pretty interesting thing i mean let's
let me just draw just to maybe give you
a little bit of intuition
let's say
that this
i don't know what the slope of f of x
really looks like and actually let's
pretend like this isn't f of x let's
pretend like this is just some arbitrary
function i'm drawing
if if this is f of x there's some curve
that does all sorts of crazy things
the the
f prime of x tells me the slope at any
point along that line so if i wanted to
know the point
the slope at say
this point right here
i could use the derivative function
to figure out the slope of the tangent
line which would be you know the tangent
line is something like
that right there
or if i wanted to figure out the slope
at say this point once again i would use
the derivative function and it would
figure it would tell me the slope of the
tangent line at that point which would
be something like that
so it's a pretty useful thing and
once i give you all the tools to
analytically solve a whole host of
derivatives then we'll actually do a
bunch of word problems and applications
of derivatives and i think you'll see
that it's a it's a really really really
useful concept so let's let's move on i
think you get the idea of how to how to
do these derivatives of polynomials
let me erase this i'm actually using
a different tool now so i think it might
be a bit easier
but let's see someone was calling me but
you're more important so i will
not answer the phone so let me
erase
this erase this make sure i'm using the
right tool
and now i'm going to introduce you
this tool doesn't have i don't think it
has a straight up
eraser actually maybe let's see if i do
it like this if i just
if i just do this
and then
let me see nope nope
if i did
well let me see if i just
no that doesn't work let me just erase
like this
old-fashioned way
it takes a little say you just have to
bear with me and then once i finish
erasing i will show you
the chain rule
this is good feels like i'm a real
teacher with a real chalkboard and a
real eraser now
almost there
this is a lot cleaner than a normal
chalkboard as well
bear with me
almost there
i'll figure out a faster way to do this
over the next couple of videos
it's pretty sad i'm showing you how to
do derivatives in calculus but i don't
know how to
erase a faster way than this
just bear with me there we're done
okay so now i'm going to show you how to
solve the derivatives of a slightly more
uh complicated type of function it's
actually i mean it's not more
complicated it's just different
so let's say
i want to
let's say f of x
is equal to
um
two x plus three
to the 5th power
and i want to figure out the derivative
of this we're going to use something
called the chain rule because one thing
we could do we could just multiply out
2x plus 3 to the fifth power and if
you've ever done that you know it's it's
it's a pain
so that's not something we want to do so
we're going to use something called the
chain rule and i'm just going to give
you a bunch of examples before i even
show you the definition of the chain
rule because i think this is something
that you just have to learn by example
so the chain rule just tells us that the
derivative of let's say this function
right
here it's just you take the derivative
of kind of the sub functions and then
you could take a derivative of the
entire function i'll tell you kind of
that formally but i think when you
introduce it formally it gets more
confusing so what i do i just take the
derivative of 2x plus 3 first and
actually let me use some colors so i
think that might simplify it so i take
the derivative of 2x plus 3. what's the
derivative of 2x plus 3 well you know
that it's just you know the derivative
of 2x which is 2
and then the derivative 3 is 0. so the
derivative of 2x plus 3 is just 2.
and then i'm going to multiply that
times the derivative of the whole thing
and i just pretend like 2x plus 3 is
just like a variable by itself so then
what's the derivative of x to the fifth
well the derivative of x to the fifth
i'm going to do that in a different
color
so the derivative of x to the fifth you
know is
is 5x to the fourth right
so it'll be five
times something
to the fourth
but here we didn't take the derivative
of x to the fifth we took the derivative
of two x plus three to the fifth so we
just put the two x plus 3 there instead
2x plus 3. so what did we do here we
just we went in kind of the inside of
the function and we took the derivative
here the derivative of 2x plus 3 was
this 2 and then we multiplied it by the
derivative of kind of the greater
function and we just pretended like the
2x plus 3 was a variable it was like x
so we got 5 instead of 5x to the fourth
we got 5 times 2x plus 3 to the fourth
and if we just simplify that
f prime of x
is equal to 2 times 5 is 10
10 times 2x plus 3
to the fourth that was a lot simpler
than multiplying out 2x plus 3 to the
fifth power and then doing the
derivatives the old way i know this was
probably a little confusing to you so
i'm going to try to do a couple of more
examples
let's say i had
let's change a little bit g of x
is equal to
let's say g of x is equal to
x squared plus 2x
plus 3
to the 8th power
so g prime
of x
is going to equal well what did we say
we take the derivative of the inside
this is called the chain we take the
derivative of the inside what's the
derivative of the inside it's
2x
plus 2 plus 0 right
take the derivative of the inside and
then we take the derivative of the whole
thing and we just pretend like this this
whole expression x squared plus 2x plus
3 is just kind of like the variable x so
if it was just
we know that the derivative of x to the
eighth is eight x to the seventh right
so it'll be eight
times something
to the seventh and that something is
this entire expression here eight times
x squared plus two x
plus three
i hope i didn't confuse you too much and
you could simplify this more in any way
because it's two x plus two times eight
times x squared plus two x plus three to
the seventh to multiply this out or to
multiply this out is a huge pain as you
know but we could simplify a little bit
we could just say let me draw a divider
here
we could say that
that equals let's see 8 times 2x 16x
plus 16
times
i'm making it really messy x squared
plus 2x plus 3 to the seventh power
hope i didn't confuse you too much in
the next presentation i'm just going to
do a ton of examples using the chain
rule and i think the more examples you
see is going to hit the point home and
then after i've done a bunch of examples
then i'm going to give you the formal
definition i think that's actually an
easier way to digest the chain rule than
giving you the formal definition first
and then showing you a bunch of examples
so i'll see you in the next presentation